happening this friday it's an event
where well you know
you actually get firefighters to
entertain you with a couple of
performances but it's all for charity
trust us all for charity it's an annual
event raises money for burn victims here
in the valley we've
highlighted this event for years and
years hector mejia live this morning
with a preview of what firefighters are
doing what they're wearing and what they
might not
say john what were you saying sorry
sherry's been distracted as
once again we try and talk about this
hector uh good morning to you sir what's
going on over there
good morning guys we are going to keep
it g this morning
you know children are watching so we're
going to keep a g we're going to go
straight to the action and show some of
the
dance moves firefighters getting ready
all week long actually
longer than that for a couple of months
as they get ready for this huge night
big old production
they're working on and it's all
happening friday night in downtown
here you can see some action going on
some dancing some beautiful dance moves
and joining us live
we have alan who's a board member with
the burn foundation and also
a firefighter with las vegas fire and
rescue good morning to you sir good
morning
so what are you guys getting ready for
this friday and give us a sneak peek of
what's in store a lot of people are
wondering yes so this friday is
uh our underground repeal firefighter
auction it's our annual firefighter
auction
and what we're doing is we're raising
funds for the burn foundation
go ahead tell us about that mission huge
important mission you were telling me a
little bit about it and why it's so
special for you guys
so all year round we're trying to raise
money for
burn survivors or people that have been
involved in a catastrophic event and
what we can do to help them out
and this is our biggest fundraiser it's
what we want people to come out have a
good time
but also our initiative is to raise
funds to help those people
and here we have uh caleb with his
partner practicing tell us about caleb
he's going to be
performing on friday yeah so all of our
dedicated bachelors that are really
trying to
you know be impressive on stage are
doing what caleb's doing
and getting ready so when they're on
stage they're prepared and different
performances too not just dancing
yeah so there's from many years from
before to now
there's dancing there's we got some
gentlemen that are practicing the piano
some guys that are practicing singing uh
i've heard line dancing
there's a gymnast you're singing as well
oh yeah
and you know this year new this year it
includes bachelorettes as well
yes we have two bachelorettes so 14 fire
uh firefighters total
two bachelorettes and that would be 12
bachelors
lastly tickets all the information and
where is this happening
so friday july 16th in two days at the
space
and if you go to the burn foundation you
can buy your tickets online 50 bucks or
they're 60 bucks at the door
but not sure if they'll be done and it's
all for a great cause yes awesome
all right cool well we'll be posting
those details on our website that is
eightnewsnow.com
for now reporting live hector mchill
let's show you some dance moves before
we go
um eight news now back to you guys cheri
you've emceed this event
for years before uh is that how it
usually
stays the night with the the simple
i never saw the cha-cha when i know
cha-cha i saw more of this going on back
here
that's what i saw so you know maybe it's
changed during the years and there's a
little something for everybody
so you know there's nothing wrong with
classing it up yeah
for a little while at least in the
beginning then there's then there's
various and then there's this beverages
and things change yes and two lady
bachelorettes i like that
we got lady firefighters they can get
out there too
piano someone's going to play the piano
that's interesting variety it's all
about verizon
and it's a great date packages you're
going to love it you're going to have a
great time
6